do you follow the stock market at all no
how about you at all
it's basically [ __ ] the bet everything
it's ridiculous what's happening right
now basically the stock market has
plummeted crypto market has been cut in
half the dow jones is down i don't know
you know about these types of things
i'll talk about it the dow jones which
is the number one index in the world
okay everyone talks about the dow the
dow the dow is down 10 percent the s p
500 another major index the major index
in america down 10 percent the nasdaq
which i'm sure you've heard of nasdaq
100 down 100 i'm sorry
nasdaq 100 down 15
the russell yeah okay the russell 2000
which are like small companies down 18
crypto bitcoin was at 69 000 now it's
closer to 35 000 so it's almost cut in
half ethereum also even worse cut in
half so basically it's a it's ultimately
a test of what's real and what's not and
this is what is needed so you how you
said how are they making money or
they're not
this is what is needed it's a correction
this is what happens there's you know
that you're familiar with the fear or
greed index fear this is something that
they balance in investing are people
being too greedy are they being too
scared scared money don't make money so
basically it says
warren buffett quote be fearful when
people are greedy and be greedy when
people are fearful so what does that
mean
when everyone was making money off
crypto and all these idiots are making
money on dogecoin and everyone's trading
be very weary
and
you know just be very fearful because
something's going to happen allah this
the market's tanked but now if you
actually want to make money right now on
everyone's scared and the market's
tanking now is the time to start
investing isn't it always going to be
like the people who know things are
going to
upset the the scale and then the people
who are always not in the know are
always going to be but here's the here's
the trick amber here's the trick you
ready yeah nobody knows no come on
nobody knows do you ever really win
nobody knows the only people that end up
winning are long-term investors
like jimmy uh jim what jimmy donaldson
mr beast
10 years ago he was a nobody now he's
making 54 million dollars a year the
long game always wins the people who get
famous quick make money quick it never
works out for them very rarely does it
so be fearful when people are greedy
yeah be greedy when people are fearful
but i think a lot of it is strategy too
yeah like you know what i don't know i
feel like before covert a lot of ceos
started selling their companies and then
came back bought it out you know what i
mean knowing what was happened was going
to happen well
thank you for that example during covid
march of 2020 the market tank i'm in a
group uh text message with like about a
bunch of like higher-end financial
advisor type my boys that are you know
kind of have done very well for
themselves
and one guy sold all his [ __ ] like in
march so he got a hot tip and a bunch of
the guys in the group are like bro you
should have told us it's [ __ ] up how
are you gonna let your boys know blah
blah blah six months later the market
which tanked tanked during covid was
higher than it was before meaning six
months later
all of the gains came back and homie was
still on the sidelines waiting for the
right opportunity so what they say is
it's not about timing the market it's
about time in
the market anyway we'll teach you guys
some lessons you're going to pick up a
billionaire too boom
you